[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
françois-xavier bellamy bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous députés européens
dans des républicains on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour l'interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par stéphane bern et de
ouest france pour l'heure stéphane
bonjour bonjour et on va parler
évidemment des législatives pour
commencer françois-xavier bellamy est
républicain qui obtiennent 61 députés 64
avec leurs alliés de lui dit c'est loin
de la centaine que vous aviez jusqu'à
maintenant est ce que c'est quand même
un bon résultat compte tenu du contexte
ou pas je voudrais commencer par dire
mon admiration à tous les collègues qui
ont été réélus ou élus dans cette
élection qui est incroyablement
difficile bien sûr on partait d'un
contexte de crise qui est toujours
d'actualité pour notre famille politique
on sait qu'aujourd'hui on aura tout à
reconstruire mais mais grâce à eux grâce
à ceux qui ont mené cette bataille grâce
à ce qu'ils ont gagné parfois aussi à
ceux qui ont malheureusement
perdu ce combat a compliqué et bien
grâce à chacun d'entre nous avons
aujourd'hui la possibilité de peser dans
la vie démocratique d'une manière
absolument inédite et nous avons
l'espoir de reconstruire cette famille
politique dont je crois là la france a
certainement plus besoin que jamais au
cours des années qui viendront et on va
reparler la reconstruction mais dont
vous êtes satisfait 61 députés
non non c'est évidemment la mesure de
cette crise que notre famille politique
travers c'est une certitude la droite a
eu l'occasion de gouverner la france
dans le passé à de nombreuses reprises
aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons avec un
groupe qui est évidemment bien plus
faible que celui que nous avons connu
bien plus faible que celui que nous
connaîtrons à l'avenir j'en suis
convaincu mais ce que je dis c'est que
nous sommes encore là et que il va
falloir faire avec la droite que la
droite à l'occasion de peser dans le
débat et qu'elle l'aura cette
possibilité grâce au courage de ceux qui
montent en porter et je tiens à dire
quand même c'est très important par tous
les députés de droite où les candidats
de droite étaient présents au deuxième
tour ils sont ceux qui ont été le plus
massivement choisi dans
l'entre-deux-tours parlée par les
électeurs cela dit la force de la
confiance qu'ils ont su susciter dans
les circonscriptions où ils sont engagés
on a des candidats qui au premier tour
ont fait des scores absolument
exceptionnel 40 45 % parfois au 2e tour
ont creusé l'écart et je crois qu'il
faut souligner la solidité de ses élus
et aujourd'hui une certaine manière
c'est c'est à eux de nous dire ce que ce
que les français attendent de notre
famille politique pour les années qui
viendront alors vous avez un groupe plus
petit mais qui va être en situation de
peser comme vous dites parce qu'il est
en position clé pour arbitrer un certain
nombre de textes comment ce groupe petit
ou va-t-il se comporter à l'assemblée
nationale
alors c'est la première chose à dire je
crois que l'élection législative que
nous venons de vivre faisons ce constat
tout simplement elle témoigne de la
crise profonde que traverse notre
démocratie aujourd'hui par le bilan des
manuels macron y compris le bilan des
semaines qui viennent de s'écouler le
président de la république n'a pas
obtenu de majorité claire et les
français en témoigner ce faisant leur
insatisfaction profonde ils ont montré
que l'élection présidentielle avait été
un choix non pas d'adhésion mais un
choix de rejet comme on l'a souvent
dénoncé le fonds s'est tu mécanique de
la peur que le président de la
république avait cherché à installer
elle n'aboutit pas à la construction
d'une majorité politique claire
ça vous inquiète non c'est de la famille
c'est très inquiétant pour notre
démocratie et je pense que tous ceux qui
ont fait campagne j'ai été un peu
partout en france soutenir des candidats
de notre famille politique pour cette
élection législative je les ai vécus
avec eux on voit à quel point les
français se détournent de la politique
en général à quel point ils témoignent
de leurs distances à l'égard de la
démocratie et on voit au fond dans cette
élection législative le résultat de
l'ambiance de la société française
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de dynamique
claire nulle part il n'ya pas des lampes
fort il n'y a pas de mandat qui soit
réellement consistant qui soit envoyée
par le peuple français à l'occasion de
cette élection initiative et pourquoi
pourquoi parce que cette élection elle
s'est jouée sur des ambiguïtés de la
part de nos concurrents ambiguïté d'
emmanuel macron donc personne ne peut
dire au fond quel est son véritable
programme de gauche un moment et qui n'a
cessé y compris au cours des derniers
jours de discréditer précisément la
démocratie représentative qu'il faudrait
au contraire à laquelle il faudrait
redonner toute sa consistance l'idée du
conseil national de la refondation qui
déboule comme ça à quelques jours de
l'élection législative
sans qu'on sache exactement ce que cela
veut dire et qui fait suite à la
convention pour le climat qui fait suite
à l'opération sur l'avenir de l'europe
opérations suspendues biens de violences
dans ce heureusement c'est ainsi à noter
celui des aveux parce que les français
n'en peuvent plus de ces ambiguïtés ils
ont besoin de clarté de la même manière
la nuque baisses étaient fondées elles
aussi sur l'ambiguïté et on voit que dès
le lendemain cette coalition explose les
vous avons le devoir d'être clair vous
me demandiez comment se comporter et
bien nous serons clair nous sommes dans
l'opposition emmanuel macron nous
restons dans l'opposition à emmanuel
macron comme l'a rappelé hier le conseil
stratégique grattements ça se traduit
par quoi une opposition systématique ou
une opposition constructive c'est pas la
même chose et le ministre clément boon
qui a une bonne formule qui dit les
français nous ont livré un meuble en kit
mais sans nous donner le mode d'emploi
est ce que demain à l'assemblée
nationale c'est le groupe parlementaire
des républicains qui va tenir le mode
d'emploi c'est vous qui avez des clients
main ou pas de fait nous avons
aujourd'hui l'occasion de défendre nos
priorités mais nous le ferons encore une
fois dans la clarté moi je ne crois pas
qu'ils aient de mode d'emploi a inventé
la vérité de cette élection c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des députés
les républicains qui sont arrivés avec
un mandat clair sur un projet explicite
nous savons ce que nous avons proposé à
nos électeurs ce que nous défendons
auprès d'eux depuis des années
maintenant et donc tout ce qui ira
évidemment dans le sens que nous n'avons
cessé de défendre et il est évident que
nous le voterons cela a été fait aussi
au cours des dernières années si nous
avons enfin une réforme des retraites
courageuse comment votent aurions-nous
courageuse
moi je ça veut dire avec un âge légal de
départ à 65 ans c'est même pas oui bien
sûr mais mais en tous les cas c'est même
pas tellement le sujet le le sujet c'est
de dire que ce que nous avons défendu
c'est à dire l'idée qu'il faut que la
france se remette à travailler pour
produire ce dont elle a besoin pour
retrouver sa compétitivité pour
retrouver son rayonnement économique
dans le monde pourrait de nouveau de
reconquérir son indépendance cette
france qui aujourd'hui déficitaires
commercialement depuis des années ce qui
nous permettra de renouer avec le
travail nous le soutiendrons ce qui nous
permettra de valoriser le travail nous
le soutiendrons mais clair c'est pas
d'accord de législature mais des
discussions au cas par cas sur la nous
restons donc position mais nous restons
dans l'opposition et je crois qu'il faut
redire à quel point le président de la
république a le devoir d'entendre le
message qui lui a été envoyé par les
français et pour moi il s'agit pas
seulement d'examiner texte par texte ce
qui doit être discutée et ce qui devrait
être voté il s'agit d'abord de dire au
président de la république que le
gouvernement qu'il envoie devant le
français a été disqualifié par cette
élection législative il faut changer ce
gouvernement comment maintenir au
pouvoir il me semble que comment nous
pouvons comment nous pourrions imaginer
que soit maintenue aujourd'hui le
responsabilité des ministres qui sont
soit profondément discrédité soit
profondément controversé un mini un
ministre de l'intérieur qui de manière
évidente a menti sur une affaire qui
engage la crédibilité de la france
devant l'europe toute entière
comment peut-il comment peut-il rester
en poste cette élection est aussi le
signe
il me semble qu en tous les cas il ya
quelque chose qui doit être entendu dans
le message des français à l'occasion de
ce deuxième tour de l'élection
législative votre raisonnement
s'applique
comment la droite pourrait l imaginer
rester silencieuse quand des pans
entiers de la politique éducative ne
passe pas au parlement c'est pour ça
vous voyez je pense pas qu'on doive on
restait seulement à une analyse texte
par texte il ya beaucoup de politiques
qui sont menées par le gouvernement qui
ne passe pas devant le parlement c'est
le cas de l'éducation parce que
l'éducation nationale pour beaucoup de
raisons est l'objet de peu de textes
législatifs il me semble qu'il est très
clair aujourd'hui que là encore le
résultat cette élection législative
porte avec lui un message est que le
président de la république ne devrait
pas maintenir en poste un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui est on avait
parlé sur votre plateau massivement
controversé qui alimente aujourd'hui les
thèses des colonials l'intersection des
rues du mans la transmission de gérald
darmanin de pap ndiaye s qu'elisabeth
bornes elle peut rester et pourquoi ne
pourrait-elle pas rester elle a gagné
dans sa circonscription qu'est ce qui
ferait qu elle ne pourrait pas rester en
poste aujourd'hui en tous les cas c'est
d'abord elle a gagné de peu dans sa
circonscription dans une sauce
inscriptions qui pourrait pourtant passé
pourraient être acquises au maquereau
nisme encore une fois je le redis la
question est moins celle de savoir
comment les républicains vont se
comporter leur ligne est claire et d'une
certaine manière nous sommes
nombreux la page que vous dites nous
mais le nous il englobe
françois copé par exemple lui demande un
jour au psg a vécu hier au comité
stratégique du parti il reconnaît
lui-même d'ailleurs sa voix est
infiniment de minoritaires et l'immense
majorité de notre famille politique est
je crois une immense majorité des
députés qui ont été élus à l'occasion de
cette élection législative je crois que
c'est eux qu'il faut écouter parce
qu'encore une fois c'est eux qui savent
ce que les français leur ont demandé de
dire et de faire dans cette assemblée
nationale ne veut pas que aujourd'hui
nous nous laissions dissoudre dans le
maquereau nice nous avons besoin de
clarté nous avons besoin de constance
comme le dit votre confrère vincent
treulet devillers dans son éditorial du
figaro aujourd'hui le maître mot pour la
droite aujourd'hui ça doit être la
clarté la clarté qui d'autre que jean
françois copé est ce qu'un a pas d'autre
film juin par exemple qui a été élue
nouvellement députés disait il ya
plusieurs casernes dans notre famille
politique
est ce que vous craignez quand même que
certains membres c'est une politique
certains députés à y voir du côté des
manuels macro et kate votre famille
politique moi je vous dis toujours la
même chose je lui dis d'ailleurs ici
même à votre micro il ya quelques
semaines ceux qui pensent que emmanuel
macron est défend la ligne qu'il faut
pour l'avenir de notre pays ont tout à
fait le droit de rejoindre emmanuel
macron et si ils estiment que c'est leur
responsabilité qu'en conscience ils
doivent le soutenir et bien qu'il rentre
dans la majorité nous nous resterons
dans l'opposition et je peux vous
garantir que c'est ce que veulent
l'immense majorité des députés qui
viennent d'être élus c'est ce que
veulent l'immense majorité des
parlementaires des élus
quand vous voyez vos scores aux
dernières élections et ce que vous dites
pas que les électeurs de facto ils sont
déjà partis manuel nos électeurs il
avait dans toutes les sections les
circonscriptions de france s'il le
souhaitait l'occasion de voter pour des
candidats de la majorité présidentielle
si ils ont élu dans soixante et une
circonscription des parlementaires de la
droite c'est parce qu'ils veulent que
les idées de la droite soit défendue à
l'assemblée nationale et c'est parce
qu'il ne confonde pas eu la droite avec
la politique du président de la
république et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
a de moins en moins on a moins que
jamais l'occasion de confondre les deux
donc encore une fois je le redis c'est
un service à rendre non seulement à la
reconstruction de notre famille
politique pour l'avenir mais surtout et
c'est le plus important à la démocratie
française il faut retrouver la clarté la
constance le courage de la cohérence et
c'est à partir de ce courage là que nous
pourront redonner confiance pour tous
les français dans la vie démocratique
c'est entre fusion généralisée qui aussi
bien à la nu pèse que dans la majorité
présidentielle
hecker les français elle discrédite la
politique et la démocratie
de leur assemblée nationale on peut
partager ou non ses idées mais la vérité
c'est que le rassemblement national a
fait campagne sous ses couleurs et
personne ne lui demande d'ailleurs ce
qu'il va faire aujourd'hui et c'est tout
à fait normal moi je crois au pluralisme
démocratique c'est très bien je pense
qu'il faut respecter ce pluralisme et ça
suppose que chacun assume de manière
cohérente les idées qu'il défend devant
les français dont vous êtes très très
clair un rapprochement entre les
républicains et la majorité
présidentielle même un rapprochement
négocié avec mettons un troisième
premier ministre qui viendrait des rangs
des républicains et un gouvernement
réaménagé selon une feuille de route que
les républicains pourraient définir
c'est non
même pas en rêve non encore une fois ce
que lisent on sait que je crois assez
absolument fondamental il faut que le
président de la république entende le
message de cette élection législative je
pense que le maquereau nisme s'est
terminée si vous voulez mon avis le
maquereau nice mais c'est à dire cette
espèce de situation improbable dans
laquelle un homme décidé tout seul
depuis l'elysée de ce que le parlement
allait ensuite être chargées d'exécuter
on voit bien que les députés de la
majorité présidentielle qui avait une
majorité absolue dans le dernier
quinquennat n'ont servi qu'à exécuter à
mettre en scène la pièce que le
président de la république écrivait tout
seul de son bureau élyséen et bien ça
c'est fini tu allais tant mieux d'une
certaine manière je pense qu'on va
redécouvrir qu'il y a un parlement dans
ce pays que ce parlement où des
précisions contenues sur le la
clarification la fin des ambiguïtés
comment ça se passe concrètement demain
est-ce que vous pensez que les députés
républicains pourraient discuter avec la
nuque avec le ration nationale sur
certains textes pour faire barrage au
gouvernement ou encore donner leur vote
où ça c'est non non plus je ne nous
reconnaît assez peu de convergence avec
l'extrême gauche ça veut dire pas des
changes jamais par exemple avec les
députés du rpt à ce monsieur est ainsi
très simple cible et moi je vis ça au
parlement européen tous les jours parce
que parlement européen on est dans la
même situation que dans cette assemblée
nationale qui se dessine il n'y a pas un
groupe qui a la majorité absolue ce qui
veut dire qu'à chaque fois qu'un texte
arrive sur la table chaque groupe doit
faire valoir ses priorités et à la fin
il s'agit pas de négocier ou de se
compromettre il s'agit seulement de
peser dans la balance pour faire avancer
les priorités
par exemple sur l'islamisme radical
puisque c'est le premier texte annoncé
par rassemblement national est ce que
vous pourriez voté avec sur la lutte
contre l'immigration est ce que vous
pourriez trouver des compromis avec leur
ascendant mais je vais vous étonner mais
au parlement européen il nous arrive de
voter des amendements que dépose le
rassemblement national si le
rassemblement national dépose un
amendement qui dit que la turquie ne
doit pas rentrer dans l'union européenne
et qu'il faut mettre fin aux
négociations d'adhésion de la turquie
avec l'union européenne nous votons cet
amendement et si nous déposons un
amendement en ce sens j'espère qu'ils
ont la cohérence des amendements ou est
ce que vous pourriez aller jusqu'à
travailler des textes communs avec eux
mais encore une fois il s'agit pas de
nous si nous proposons nos textes et je
vends ce sera très important de regarder
comment la majorité de la république en
marche d'ailleurs se comporte lorsque
nous aurons l'occasion de mettre sur la
table de l'assemblée nationale des
textes qui viendront justement
réhabiliter le travail des textes qui
permettront de mieux lutter contre
l'immigration illégale des textes qui
nous conduiront à garantir justement que
la france soit capable de retrouver sa
compétitivité bien nous verrons dans ces
moments là ce que la république ans
marchera la balle est dans le camp
aujourd'hui de ce groupe parce que je
crois que tout le monde l'a remarqué il
n'a pas la majorité absolue au fond nous
sommes dans une assemblée où tout le
monde est minoritaire mais c'est la plus
forte minorité d'une certaine manière
celle du président de la république et
donc la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir comment le président de
la république et comment son groupe
entendent le message de cette élection
législative c'est au fond d'eux que nous
attendons aujourd'hui d'abord cette
capacité de prendre en compte ce que les
français ont dit à l'occasion de cette
élection derniers mois juste sur
l'assemblée après on va parler de
l'avenir de votre famille politique la
gauche envisage de déposer une motion de
censure commune est ce que les
républicains doivent la voter ce qui
compte c'est que le gouvernement crée
les conditions pour retrouver la
capacité d'agir et je vous dis ce que je
vous disais à l'instant je pense que il
n'est pas possible que le gouvernement
le même revienne devant la situation
dans les camps pour rien faute est là
pour révocation
son sens sur sa porte évidemment un
message et nous ne voulons pas d'un
gouvernement qu'ils soient plus à gauche
encore d'un gouvernement qui penche vers
l'extrême gauche
du ministre de l'éducation nationale il
est clair que nous n'allons pas voter me
semble-t-il une motion de censure qui
viendrait de l'extrême gauche parce que
cela voudrait dire que nous voudrions à
un tournant vers l'extrême gauche
maintenant une chose est très clair
réfléchir
très clair et je crois qu'il faut que ce
soit aujourd'hui exprimer si le
gouvernement comme c'est la tradition il
n'en a pas l'obligation mais c'est la
tradition si le gouvernement demande et
la confiance de l'assemblée nationale il
me semble qu'il ne serait pas possible
aujourd'hui que la droite vote la
confiance à ce gouvernement encore une
fois je le redis nous sommes dans
l'opposition le gouvernement doit
montrer qu'il a compris ce que les
français avaient dit
de fait je ne suis pas sûr et ce sera
sans doute un signe de faiblesse mais
malheureusement ce signe de faiblesse et
lie à toutes les fragilités dont ce
quinquennat hérite je ne suis pas sûr
que le gouvernement soit aujourd'hui en
mesure de voter la confiance est bon et
bien voilà demandera pas je crois qu'il
ne le fera pas parce que malheureusement
j'ai l'impression qu'ils aient les
moyens de la série est ce que tout ça
peut se terminer autrement que par une
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale à
terme selon vous
je n'en suis pas sûr encore une fois je
vous le redis moi je suis d'un parlement
je travaille tous les jours dans un
parlement où il n'y a pas de majorité
absolue ça ne veut pas dire que ça ne
fonctionne pas ça veut dire au contraire
que d'une certaine façon dans ce
contexte là vient le parlement pèse
vraiment et moi ce que j'espère ce que
je crois c'est que dans ce parlement
nous aurons les moyens de faire entendre
les préoccupations des parlementaires
européens que vous disent vos petits
camarades de strasbourg et bruxelles sur
ce qui nous arrive en france aujourd'hui
mais ça les inquiète tu trouves ça
normal ça les amuse on ça les amuse pas
je crois que l'europe prend très au
sérieux la crise que traverse la france
aujourd'hui on se représente souvent
emmanuel macron comme une sorte de grand
leader européen mais la vérité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui pour nos partenaires
européens la france est un pays qui
traverse une crise très profonde cette
crise est à nous la connaissons elle se
matérialise dans des indicateurs comme
notre déficit budgétaire notre déficit
commercial au fond nous voyons bien le
décrochage économique de la france mais
ce décrochage il est surtout lundi une
forme de crise intérieure j'en suis pour
ma part convaincu je pense que la crise
éducative que traverse notre pays est
sans aucun doute ce qu'il ya de plus
préoccupant pour notre avenir et là
encore c'est une situation qui
caractérise qui singularise
malheureusement notre pays dans l'espace
européen quand nous arrivons dernier de
toute l'union européenne pour
l'apprentissage des mathématiques quand
nous voyons ce qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment même au tour du
baccalauréat je me permets d'en dire un
mot parce qu'en ce moment j'entends
remontée de tous les collègues que je
connais des alertes très préoccupé sur
le trucage des notes du bac leur cage le
trucage c'est à dire que les notes du
baccalauréat qui sont attribués par des
professeurs qui sont qualifiés constitué
comme un jury universitaire pour
délivrer le premier grade universitaire
ces notes qui devrait être normalement
respectés par l'institution elles sont
aujourd'hui il faut c'est dans beaucoup
d'académies les notes sont remonté de
1,2 deux parfois de 300
et d'ailleurs certains de vos confrères
chez libération par exemple en ont fait
l'occasion d'une investigation poussée
par ce que il ya là une espèce de
mensonges absolument dramatique on m'en
a une génération toute entière en lui
faisant croire qu'elle a le niveau pour
aller vers les études supérieures alors
même que nous n'avons pas réussi à leur
transmettre des savoirs pourtant
fondamentaux bien cette situation l ai
regardé avec inquiétude par nos
partenaires européens et je crois que ce
que parfois je vis le plus
douloureusement à bruxelles et à
strasbourg c'est le regard d'inquiétude
effectivement d'anxiété parfois même une
forme de compassion que partenaires
européens portent sur la france j'espère
que nous retrouverons notre fierté et
notre rayonnement dans le débat européen
et ça c'est aussi un enjeu des années
qui viennent sur l'avenir de votre parti
françois-xavier bel ami christian jacob
va quitter la tête des républicains il a
annoncé ce que vous êtes candidat à sa
succession
moi je ne
laisserai pas notre famille politique
tomber dans le la confusion dans
l'ambiguïté donc je prendrai toutes mes
responsabilités nous verrons bien qui
sera quaïda non je dis que nous verrons
bien qui sera candidat je ne me sens pas
par définition des des ambitions
personnelles je crois que le plus
important pour moi c'est d'assumer
n'attendez pas d'idées pour savoir si
vous le serez au par oui c'est comme ça
qu'ils auraient jamais parce que ce qui
compte c'est de regarder comment nous
allons pouvoir aborder cette élection
qui sera vital pour l'avenir de notre
famille politique ce que je vous dis
simplement ce en clair c'est un candidat
c'est bien classés vous n'irez pas si
c'est quelqu'un d'une ligne qui n'est
pas la vôtre aurélien pradié au hasard
là vous irez je défendrai mes idées et
si elles ne sont pas représentés et bien
j'assumerai mes responsabilités
j'ai choisi suis l'insee un peu plus
centriste un peu plus social c'est pas
la ligne pour l'avenir d'un républicain
c'est ça d'abord je ne poserai jamais
l'idée que la droite doit se préoccuper
des plus modestes avec l'idée que la
droite doit assumer de défendre ses
idées et son identité je ne poserai
jamais la nécessaire défense de la
culture française et de sa transmission
à la nécessité de défendre les
préoccupations sociales au contraire mon
premier engagement je suis professeur de
philosophie géant 6 dans le secondaire
pendant des années mon premier
engagement a été pour défendre les
déshérités c'était le titre de mon
premier livre les plus déshérités de
notre pays qui sont justement victimes
de l'effondrement de ce qui fait tenir
la france si la france est aujourd'hui
dans une crise profonde parce que l'état
régalien n'assume plus ses missions si
elle traverse une crise profonde parce
que nous vivons depuis trop longtemps
une immigration qui n'est pas maîtrisée
si nous traversons cette crise et
éducative eh bien ce sont les plus
modestes qui en payent le prix
aujourd'hui tard qu'est donc
social à mesure qu'elle défende notre
identité et son identité ce qui vous
déplaît comme une caisse qui ferait ou
vous direz mais là faut que j'y aille ce
n'est pas mal vous le disiez on a ce
débat aujourd'hui des voix elles sont
minoritaires je le crois aussi bien chez
les militants chez les adhérents des
républicains que chez les élus qui
viennent courageusement de remporter
cette bataille mais mais quelques voix
minoritaires nous dise après tout
finalement pourquoi ne pas se fondre
dans le maquereau nisme pourquoi ne pas
abandonner nos idées pourquoi ne pas se
dissoudre dans la majorité je ne
laisserai pas faire pour ma part une
ligne qui serait je crois totalement
contraire à ce que veulent nos électeurs
j'en suis profondément convaincu mais
aussi à ceux dont la démocratie
française a besoin pour pouvoir se
reconstruire une droite qui soit claire
aurélien pradié
encore une fois nous verrons bien ce
n'est pas d'abord une question de
personnes c'est d'abord une question de
fond et je vais vous dire une chose la
plus importante pour moi c'est derrière
la question de la position de notre
famille politique sur le plan des idées
il ya d'abord le fait que nous avons
absolument besoin de nous remettre à
travailler se remettre à travailler sur
le fond retourner au contenu revenir aux
questions qui aujourd'hui préoccupent
les français est de nouveau avoir un
discours à leur offrir qui ne soit pas
seulement la réédition de ce que la
droite a parfois répété pendant 15 20
ans aujourd'hui nous avons besoin de
trouver les moyens d'une nouvelle
histoire à partager avec les français
qu'ils soient fidèles à ce que nous
avons à leur offrir mais qui soit aussi
profondément renouvelée et ce travail de
renouvellement il est largement cette
nouvelle histoire elle doit s'écrire
sont nicolas sarkozy delà la page est
déjà tournée ou pas bien sûr mais allait
tourner parce qu'il la tournée lui même
en fait selon nicolas sarkozy
quand nicolas sarkozy
qui s'est abstenu de de soutenir sa
famille politique à l'élection
européenne puis à l'élection
présidentielle vient maintenant soutenir
des candidats de la majorité
présidentielle
10 je respecte le pluralisme chacun a le
droit de défendre ses idées y compris
les anciens présidents
jacob doit dire il vola sarkozy ne parle
plus au nom des républicains mais je
pense que tout le monde a parfaitement à
l'esprit le fait que nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui a choisi de soutenir la
majorité présidentielle dont il l'a fait
de manière explicite dans l'élection
législative
ce que je regrette c'est le caractère
finalement
très inélégant de ce comportement à
l'égard de certains ou candidats de
certains élus de notre famille politique
qu'il l'avait toujours soutenu je pense
à brigitte kuster qui a été une
remarquable députés une remarquable
maire du xviie arrondissement
je crois qu'il y avait quelque chose de
passer peu élégant dans le dans le
comportement de du lot de l'ancien
président de la république mais encore
une fois chacun fait ses choix j'ai les
choix que chacun fait doivent être
respectées ils ont au moins aujourd'hui
le mérite de la clarté merci françois
xavier bellamy merci beaucoup d'avoir
été ce matin on regarde la une d'ouest
france est fan législatives le jour
d'après c'est à la une de votre journal
merci montereau
[Musique]